[Music]  Hilary Duff is pregnant with her second  child  the younger star announced the happy  news via Instagram on Friday posting  this shot with boyfriend musician  Matthew koma guess what guys at Matthew  koma and I made a little princess of our  own and we couldn't be more excited  this is Duff's first child with Matthew  she also shares a six-year-old son Luca  with her ex-husband Mike Comrie Matthew  shared the same shot on Instagram  writing we made a baby girl she will be  as beautiful and sweet as her mother at  Hilary Duff another incredible chapter  begins the exciting news comes just  three days after Duff's older sister  Hayley welcomed her second child baby  girl Lulu gray with Beyonce Matt  Rosenberg the 30 year old expecting  actress shared this pic of the newborn  writing my new niece has arrived at  Haylie Duff she's perfection  [Music]  you